[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you mind you're harshing my mellow oh
sorry
teach me something how about patience
come on teach me anything seriously
let's do this i'm ready for it
how about these you're not ready for the
holes how hard can it be
sumo is in town what's a sumo he's a
giant sorry hank you have to do
something
right oh no no no no no no no no oh no
way you are not ready not even close
okay then we'll go together no no no not
my job not my fight and you are not
prepared so is someone going to do
something yeah is someone gonna do
something no someone's not
you know she's gonna go over there
not my student
not my problem
sword
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i know you did but this is kind of my
job i could totally take that guy
[Music]
you should know that i am a highly
trained mostly trained warrior
skilled in the ways of karate and
swordplay as well as musical theater in
your own best interest you should
surrender you're under arrest
wait uh you've got something on your
very allergic so
we're all good then
jimbo
is your plan to let him hit you until he
gets tired maybe bold plan
oh here he comes
[Music]
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
[Music]
he has told you his weakness remember
you defeat strength with smart now get
back up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
did you see what i just did there it was
beautiful mm-hmm and i would say
congratulations but since you're already
doing that yourself
let's get him to a doctor oh yeah yeah
yeah absolutely got to do that i might
have really hurt him i mean look at him
[Music]
why do you want to be a samurai
[Music]
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times maybe could use some help
himself
but where can i find
one out of here who even made that it's
you don't believe everything you read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
go get them
get back out there
[Music]
[Applause]
don't forget to land on your
send a tweet to assemble the troops
who knew an evil army could go through
so many beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the mother father cocker spaniels
going on here
the legend of hank
time to finish this
this might take a while
[Music]